irak acude a elecciones este domingo en
un momento especialmente convulso en el
país más de 25 millones de ciudadanos
están llamados a votar pero el principal
protagonista en la población es el
escepticismo la fuerte crisis que sufre
el país y la corrupción parecen ser las
principales causas aunque desde el
gobierno hicieron un llamado al voto
masivo
todos tenemos que contribuir a cambiar
la situación actual a mi llamado de los
iraquíes es que todavía tienen tiempo
hoy para votar y cambiar su realidad por
el bien de irak y su futuro yo no estaba
lejos estos comicios se celebran de
forma anticipada tras las masivas
protestas de 2019 que sacaron del poder
al ex primer ministro adel abdul mahdi
casi dos años después las
reivindicaciones siguen siendo las
mismas mejores servicios y el final de
una clase política que lleva dominando
durante años el país en este contexto la
democracia iraquí se juega su crédito y
cientos de observadores internacionales
llevan semanas monitoreando la
preparación de estos comicios están por
javi hay esperanza de tener digamos un
proceso electoral más transparente
entero justo y libre que la última vez
y eso es lo que todos esperan
sin embargo parece difícil un vuelco
electoral que saque del poder a la élite
chiíta que bajo la influencia de irán
lleva años al frente de la escena
militar y política de irak